jean-marc l'ouzbek bonjour bonjour vous
êtes candidat aux élections législatives
où vous présenter dans la
circonscription 4 celle du sud et vous
êtes sur la liste les républicains pas
c'est tout à fait ça alors pourquoi vous
présentez-vous à ce scrutin alors il y a
une problématique qui est sur l'ensemble
de la martinique c'est l'insatisfaction
des citoyens face à au travail des
politiques donc ce que ce qu'on entend
souvent
qui c'est récurrent ses yeux pas qu'à
fayoum bannu et l'opac a coûté voilà
alors quelle serait pour vous les deux
ou trois projets prioritaires que vous
souhaitez défendre si vous êtes élu à
l'assemblée nationale concernant
l'ensemble du territoire alors
concernant l'ensemble du territoire le
le projet le plus important c'est le
pouce et tout ce qui touche à la santé
la mise en place d'aidés préconisations
des débats de la démocratie sanitaire à
savoir
le choix de la sonde de la ce pour ça
pousse le choix pour se soigner le lit
soins en proximité et le développement
des infrastructures
médicales à la martinique médico social
parce que vous êtes de ceux qui
considèrent que nous n'avons pas un
système médical on est même confronté à
une situation de désert médical la
mantide est un grand désert médical
toute la martinique c'est vrai quand on
va sur le site du ministère de la santé
il ya que certaines zones qui sont
marqués comme désert médical mais après
les
différentes phases qu'ovide et les les
départs des différents médecins et
personnels de santé on se retrouve sur
toute la martinique dans une situation
catastrophique quasiment une situation
de guerre quels seraient les autres
priorités s'il fallait penser plus
concrètement à la circonscription dans
laquelle vous vous présentez savoir à
savoir celle du sud alors
pour le sud effectivement il y a les
projets qui sont en cours devrait être
mené à bien notamment le rapprochement
entre l'hôpital des trois ilets et
l'hôpital du marin et la reconstruction
de l'hôpital du saint-esprit ce sont les
projets qui pour la plupart sont déjà
adaptés mais qui ont besoin des poussées
pour que ça aille beaucoup plus vite
donc c'est le sur le sud il ya le
problème de la santé et l'autre problème
qui est un problème c'est le problème
économique et la problématique du sud et
c'est une problématique générale à la
martinique donc il ya le problème
économique
il faut trouver des
d'une intelligence pour permet pour nous
permettre de réduire les coûts d les
coudes approche de travail et dans la
caraïbe et surtout de permettre aux
consommateurs d'avoir un prix d'achat
acceptable et un salaire acceptable donc
c'est aussi la lutte contre la vie chère
la selas et la lutte contre la vie chère
et contre la précarité économique et
social et sanitaire
qu'avez vous à dire pour convaincre les
électeurs de voter pour vous alors pour
goûter à l'eau je dis aux électeurs du
sud si vous voulez vraiment un
changement souffle d'un député qui sera
à votre écoute votez pour moi je suis un
militant depuis plus de 40 ans après mon
retour de d'études
sur tous les domaines qui touchent la
santé le handicap
je siège dans pas mal de commissions je
suis président de pas mal d'instance et
mon combat c'est pour la santé pour
améliorer la prise en charge de la santé
à la martinique et pour aussi pour nous
permettre d'avoir un développement
économique à la hauteur de nos attentes
jean-marc l'ouzbek merci merci madame et
merci aux et aux eaux dieter le
martinique la première qui me coûte